yeah I was going to say uh for you like
uh you know we talked about the LA
conversation who are some of the upand
cominging LA artists that are outside of
the camp that you're just a fan of that
you're just like yo I see what you're
doing there's there's so many new guys
that are doing their thing um
x4's bub in there I ain't going to cap
I'm going give it to uh old Su right now
cuz you know a lot of [__]
don't want to mention his name they
don't want to really theying real
numbers yeah you feel me and I know lot
guys I know yeah I know they see little
bro you feel me but they going to act
like they don't that's what they do you
feel me they going to wait till
something big happen and everybody else
is on to it and then they going to want
to [__] with him but hey he does have
the song underrated for a reason cuz he
is an underrated guy it's a crazy like
he's doing numbers that like most
artists aren't I be feeling like that
underrated [__] be like an
understatement
mhm yeah for sure yeah know zo's dope
have you guys got to work at all n but
we be chopping it up about doing music
he's a good kid man it ain't nothing to
do nothing you feel me that's easy man
yeah that's easy you feel me we had try
the truth up here a couple of weeks ago
and he had alluded to the fact that you
guys have an unreleased project
somewhere yeah we got we got me and Trey
got music yeah yeah me and Tre got mus I
didn't realize cuz he was telling us
like how he has like unreleased albums
with so many people and I was just like
damn like that's one [__] I know
that his work ethnic is crazy bro like
he'll drop a project [__] on his phone
he's like bro I got a Alum with this
person everybody I don't know if you
heard like you know cuz he do the Amon
like you know he he got he got the
series of that [__] you feel me I think
he's working on a new one I don't think
you heard that one bro no he didn't play
me that one but he played me some other
[__] he played me some crazy [__] you
should have had him play you that the
latest I'm on he been that see I'm I'm
saying too much no he talked about it a
little bit bro he got every he he got
got a lot of [__] on there bro
I almost want to get on that
[__] you should [__] someone
should do like a West Coast version of
that try to unify the city put everybody
fact that's what I'm saying we need to
do something cuz we ain't really got too
much going on out here like that you
feel me I think we need another uh not a
uh we are the world but uh n we need
something like that for La what's that
record that ice cube did I mean EAS e
did what uh he did with uh yoyo he did
with everybody like all
be [__] 10 minute song 10 minute song
bro every the politics throw the
politics out the window ice you too we
bringing you back outside you too cuz I
know you got something to say spit some
game to these youngsters man they need
it no I think it'd be dope too cuz like
you said like you know I think big sea
did something like that he had a bunch
of people he did the Detroit freestyle
or Cipher and it had yeah there was like
12 Detroit rappers and like a lot of
them that was on his latest album right
but did he do a video to it no but
because a lot of the guys had issues
with each other but at the end of the
day it was kind of dope cuz you you
might have heard songs two guys on a
song that you wouldn't heard before that
you would have never heard before yeah
100% man but see only like people like
Big Sean can do that everybody can't you
know what I mean everybody don't got
pulled like that in their City you feel
me so it got to be somebody that you
know the city respect that should have
be hard yeah there's the idea someone go
execute it all right there it is